all right
[Music]
it is my pleasure to introduce Ryan
feeling
and
my day job is I'm a long-range
forecaster and so I pay attention to
people who are good at forecasting and
Ryan has this absolutely unerring
ability to see emerging connections way
ahead of the crowd way ahead of the pack
and what I've watched is the first time
she'll mentioned something new
you know everywhere I go huh that's
that's kind of surprising and
interesting then after a while everybody
says oh oh oh in about a year later oh
now I start to get get it but then
eventually that turns back to surprise
because when you realize what you think
you got really was only part of the
story and Ryan was doing something much
deeper and much more surprising so all I
can say is I invite Ryan up to the stage
prepared to be surprised Ryan
thank you
this is a painting by Isabella Kirkland
an incredible artist who's actually in
the audience
its title is back and it depicts 48
species that were all brought back from
the brink of Extinction
this happened just at the end of the
late 1990s and it was done using
traditional tools of conservation that
means these species were brought into
captivity if needed and be rewilded over
time their habitat was protected they
stopped over hunting these are all the
common tools of conservation
but now as we enter into the 21st
century we have new conservation
challenges we have invasive species like
never before we have novel Wildlife
diseases we have smaller and smaller
populations of endangered species losing
genetic diversity and all of that is
compounded by climate change and
everyone in this room knows that the
world is warming and even the latest
projections show that it's going to get
way worse and we're going to lose
biodiversity along the way
now my background actually is in
healthcare I spent several decades in it
and I saw the Human Genome Project when
it was launched
and I knew it was going to be
transformative for health care I could
see the emerging view of personalized
medicine where we could have targeted
Therapeutics and precise Diagnostics and
then we could see this happening with
Precision agriculture as well
and the foundation of that biotechnology
platform really begins with genomic
sequencing high level sequencing and
bioinformatics
and continued with advances in cell
culturing advances in reproductive
techniques and we could see at the time
that genome editing was coming on the
horizon quite fast with Precision Gene
editing
but this platform
had not yet been applied to conservation
and my husband Stuart brand who's a
co-founder of revive and restore we were
both thinking 10 some years ago what if
these tools could be used to help solve
some of the emerging problems in
conservation
and for those of you who know Stuart in
the long now Foundation you won't be
surprised that he opined well you could
probably even use these Technologies to
bring back an extinct species
and the passenger pigeon became one of
our Flagship projects
we started within the long now
Foundation where this idea was incubated
and Stuart and I launched a series of of
meetings with Scientists from around the
world we brought in genome Engineers
social scientists and ethicists to weigh
the benefits and the risk of these kinds
of projects and it became very clear
that what we needed to do is actually
start to socialize these ideas that
these tools were going to actually be
used in conservation and with that we
coined the term de-extinction and we
took it to a Ted stage we brought 18
scientists that were actually doing
genome editing and beginnings of
de-extinction work all over the world we
brought them to the stage where they
could hash out some of these issues at
National Geographic
all along the way where we were creating
this we could see that these tools could
be used to help endangered species
and with that we actually named our
organization revive and restore to keep
our eye on the prize which was that it
was really not just about Reviving
individual species but it was really
about ecological restoration
and the first chance we had to work on a
project that was really so profound for
organization was with the black-footed
ferret we got a call from fish and
wildlife and we heard the story of the
black-footed ferret
it used to range across the Great Plains
from Mexico to Canada
and that was until in the 1800s this
land actually became agricultural fields
and the black-footed ferrets and their
primary source of prey which is the
prairie dog
were all literally exterminated and by
1981 they were none
until one small population was found in
matitsi Wyoming
Wyoming Game and Fish brought that small
population into captivity bred them over
time and very successfully have
reintroduced them to over 30 sites back
into their original range
however over 30 years all 10 500 ferrets
have been bred in captivity from just a
Founder gene pool of seven ferrets that
had been wild caught now everybody knows
that inbreeding is not a great thing and
when species get into smaller and
smaller populations they run the risk of
going down the extinction Vortex when
smaller populations cause greater
genetic drift lower fertility counts and
even become more susceptible to Wildlife
diseases increasing their mortality
now when we got the call from Fish and
Wildlife to ask if we could help the
first thing we said was there any other
population that you can bring in to
restore uh genetic diversity because
that's the typical tool in technology
bring in a population from another area
and increase fertility lower the
mortality rate increase the population
and becomes more stable
but there was no other population for
the black-footed ferret
so we heard that within the San Diego
frozen Zoo Back 40 years ago somebody
was prescient enough to actually Bank
cell lines from two other individuals
that had been wild caught in 1981 but
had never contributed to the gene pool
with that we did the genomic sequencing
on those two cell lines and we found
that They Carried up to three times more
genetic diversity than any living ferret
so if we could actually clone those
ferrets we could start to build up that
population not by moving animals but by
moving genes by partnering with the San
Diego Zoo and a partner viogen as a
cloning company and with U.S fish and
wildlife under their permit
in 2020 we cloned Elizabeth Anne she's
the first
she's the first endangered species in
America to ever be cloned
now this is an amazing success story and
and it was a first for conservation to
actually use these Technologies in this
way but to me what's actually almost
more amazing is the fact that scientists
back in 1980s were prescient enough to
start to think about cryopreservation
now cloning didn't exist then at all
they didn't know what they were going to
do with these cells and that got us
thinking what else has been ever cryo
preserved
it turns out that less than 14 percent
of U.S endangered species have any form
of cryopreservation that includes plants
and animals out of the 1500 that's an
alarming low number and it's a
particularly alarming low number when
you realize the rate of Extinction loss
just in the last hundred years and the
trend keeps going up
so with that we started talking with
officials at Fish and Wildlife service
and we suggested to them that if we
could figure out why this isn't
happening that we could actually help
create protocols and a and actually a
road map to help ensure that every
species
that is endangered in the U.S and the
Fish and Wildlife service has a
responsibility to actually get them back
off the list
we've said why don't they just include
in that whole process taking a cell
culture and ensuring that they that
species has a reference genome that can
be open access and used by researchers
all over the world
so with this idea we're trying to
actually Bank species for the present to
help make better management decisions
based on their DNA but the truth is
they're really going to be put in the
bank to also help future generations
with unknown technologies that are
Unthinkable today but could be
transformative in the future
and here's our partner Seth Willey this
is actually the same guy who called us
to ask could we help him with the
black-footed ferret Ten Years Later Seth
is a major partner in this whole
initiative
you know we're responsible in the
southwest region there's about 200
threatened endangered species Nationwide
but we're responsible for about 1500
threatened endangered species and it got
me wondering you know are we doing our
part to set up future Generations the
same way somebody set up Blackfoot
Affair for that success 30 years before
by biobanking by cryogenically
preserving that specimen that sample
and the answer we came to was
Hit or Miss I mean we're doing it in
Little Bits here and there you know in
conservation if one of the first
premises is save what you have
this is one tool that gives us that
option to save what we have not for
academic purposes but for recovery for
genetic rescue and push species back to
the point of being biologically viable
in this game in conservation endangered
species recovery we're entrusted to
protect some of the nation's most
valuable and unique biological resources
that conservation Legacy is entrusted to
us and we're responsible for trying to
arrest a species decline to manage
threats and to bring species back from
the brink
genetic diversity took millions of years
to evolve and
you know we're losing it on our watch
but it's not too late right there's
still great opportunity for those
Critters and for many others it's our
responsibility to try to do what we can
to save what's there today
so that's what we're
the Mexican role
it is native to New Mexico and Arizona
there are only 200 left in the wild
today and on a routine vet check last
month the fueled biologist team working
with revive and restore actually was
able to sample that Mexican wolf
send off the sample to our culturing
partner with viogen and it's now on its
way for sequencing and we'll be going
for long-term storage at a federal
facility so one down we've got another
1500 to do you know we've talked about
crowd preservation with mammals and we
started there because really to be quite
honest they're the easiest to do but for
many organisms it's incredibly hard
and we're working on some Innovative
research to actually try to figure out a
solution to that but probably nothing is
more important right now than working
with coral there are over 800 species of
reef building corals and coral reefs
plays such an incredible role in
ecosystem they support fish mammals they
also provide incredible support to
humans they protect our Shores and they
create the livelihood for over a billion
people
and we're losing coral reefs at an
alarming rate projections Say by 2050 we
may lose 90 percent of the coral reach
from bleaching now bleaching is not
always 100 extinction because if Coral
have a chance to rebound the next year
with cooler Waters and less
acidification and and no fishing
trawling on them and everything else if
they don't have repeated insults they
can actually come back
and so we need to capture that
biodiversity before it's really gone so
that we can actually help bring those
reefs back to fruition and we're working
right now with a project with Mary
hagerdorn a leading scientist at the
Smithsonian
let's hear from Mary
I've been working on the
cryopreservation of marine species since
1993 and I realized it was going to be
important because you could tell the
oceans were going to be in trouble from
climate change initially when I started
I was really just trying to work out the
science of how we do this but then it
became very clear that things were
changing very rapidly and climate change
and bleaching events were happening and
you know I became very worried that we
needed to get this science done quickly
I work on the conservation of coral and
I use human fertility techniques to do
this basically we are crowd preserving
or freezing however we want to think of
it on gametes the sperm and the larvae
of coral as well as small fragments of
coral and the reason we are interested
in fusing cryopreservation is that it
allows us to stop time really we can
freeze coral and keep them for a day in
our bank or 10 years or 100 years or a
thousand years so it gives us the
ability to use this material today or
save it for many many years in the
future to potentially reseed the ocean
one of the major outcomes of our
rothesis is scalability we want to be
able to cryo preserve Coral easily and
cheaply so that every professional that
wants to around the world can form their
own cry or preserve Banks of coral and
thus speed up the process of secure
during the biodiversity and genetic
diversity of coral
so Mary's project is one of eight that
revive and restore is funding right now
we call it the advanced Coral tool kit
and we have researchers working at
understanding the underlying genetics
that allow some reefs to be resilient
and continue in the warming Waters some
that may even show signs of resilience
to disease
so as these scientists are working
they're developing the ability to create
Coral stem cells that could be used to
repopulate reefs as well as new
techniques using proteomics in other
parts of research to figure out how to
combine these tools so that we can
actually make a big difference when we
can make an effort at restoration
now we've talked about prior
preservation for a bit here but I want
to make it really clear that one of the
most simple and and what should be a
ubiquitous tool for conservation is
genomic sequencing that foundational
level for everything
and as sequencing costs have plummeted
over the years this is a tool that I
just wish more conservationists could
actually access
um and we're doing our effort to try to
make it more ubiquitous
we have two projects I want to talk
about that I think are really exciting
just in the way that they're using that
genetic insight to make better
management decisions around these
endangered species and the first one
takes us uh to Kenya with an Irishman
named Andy Tai who's been doing some
incredible work
arabico is the largest remaining
remnants of coastal forests in all of
East Africa and it has a high degree of
endemic species and there's a population
of elephants that are currently living
in this Forest which in the past would
have been connected to other populations
of elephants including those in Savo and
for the north side but now they're
surrounded by an electric fence because
it's such a dense environment it's been
very difficult to actually count how
many albums are in there and it's very
difficult to manage group of any animals
if you don't know how many exist
where this project is kind of pushing
new boundaries is that this this will be
the first time a snip array has been
developed for Savannah elephants Snips
are single nucleotides polymorphisms so
basically one base pair in the genome
where individuals differ and when you
amalgamate all those differences across
an individual's genome that pattern of
steps is unique to the individual so by
using this approach we can see how many
individuals are in the forest and the
way that we're doing that is
non-invasively using Scott
in arabico we have a unique situation
where in the dry season all of the
elephants in the forest are forced to
visit one watering hole and what this
means is that we can get a snapshot of
every element in the forest as it comes
to drink it will relieve itself and
leave us a sample and as we sample over
the course of two or three weeks we
should in theory cover the entire
population
knowing this Wildlife authorities and
can you will have a clear idea of the
pressures that are on the forest and if
the number is quite High it will
indicate to Wildlife authorities that
perhaps some elephants should be
translocated or a wildlife Corridor
should be put in in a way almost like a
release file with a unique part of our
project is that we are helping to
develop a local lab in Kenya and by
having it based in country
it means that these sorts of projects
could be happening with much higher
frequency and are reliant on people like
me flying in salesiding stuff like this
ideally in the future human civilization
will have space for nature but at the
moment it's a fight so areas like
arabico sukoke
need to be protected in their entirety
which includes the elephants and all the
Aromas are in there so that in the
future when we have space and and
tolerance they'll be able to spread out
uh this is true of all wild places
around the world
what I love about that project is that
these elephants are absolutely invisible
from the sky so they really don't know
the size of the population and they
don't know the level of inbreeding that
could be happening in a closed
population so by looking at that
individual fingerprint of those animals
they not only know of their genetic
diversity but they will begin to even
understand what plants they're eating
and how they might even create a
migratory path for them now using
genomic insight has a a very different
take in a very interesting situation
close to our home here in California
this is a healthy kelp forest and this
is the way it used to be from Baja
California to Alaska Rich diverse
ecosystem creating the habitat for
millions of organisms and nurturing
mammals along the way now what creates
this healthy ecosystem is the sea star
there are eight different species of sea
stars all up along the coast where they
should be and they got hit very hard by
unknown invasive pathogen
and it's called sea star wasting disease
and it absolutely disintegrates CC Stars
now
that billions of sea stars used to be
here until 2013.
and what is replacing them
is all purple sea urchins it's been
identified that we've lost 95 percent of
our kelp all along this West Coast it's
a horrific number these are the Bold
kelp the ones that should be like a
forest
and these urchin Barons are terrifying
particularly because they can last for
up to 50 years they just go dormant it's
a crazy horrible situation and right now
there's a lot of different ideas of how
to remove these urchins there's an
urchin Baron that can be seen that is
400 miles long off our Coast from Marin
County to the Oregon border there's lots
of Technology but there's one technology
when it was proposed to us for research
that we thought biotech might have a
solution and I'm going to let Mike
Dawson tell that story
the question for us was is there a way
to reintroduce the sunflower sea star to
California Oregon and Washington and to
help those populations that are
reintroduced be more resilient to Future
change right whether that's changes in
ocean temperature ocean acidification or
other path breaks of wasting disease
and so the way we approach this is
actually to try to work out what
diversity was remaining or what
diversity is survived that's after the
wasting disease and having identified
Those portions of the genome we're
developing a way to rapidly assess the
diversity of genomes
to identify which animals should have a
tendency to be resilient wasting disease
we're now collaborating with the team in
Washington to use the information that
we have by the genomics in a breeding
program to restore populations in the
wild
with an age Conservancy we're now
actually collaborating to try to do that
part of it the next part of that project
will be to take the tools that we're
developing with the providing restore
into that actually more you know real
applied setting that is being flown some
goal would become more willing to try
Technical Solutions to conservation
problems in part because we've just
learned a huge map more about Marine
systems in the last several decades you
know over that same period of time two
to three decades we and the general
population become much much more aware
about how severe the current threats
actually are so the need for action
and so the idea is that by restoring
populations of sea stars we would also
be able to help build the resilience of
Health forest ecosystems
biotechnology being an interesting part
of the solution but let's be clear it's
not going to be the magic fix it's going
to take all kinds of innovation and
Technology from robots to Aerial surveys
to you know divers actually removing
them in great quantities but it's the
combination it's the integration of
these Technologies it is starting to
happen that is exactly why we started
this organization
but let's talk about Birds now
one in eight species of birds are
threatened globally with Extinction it's
an alarming number half of them are in
Decline Hawaii has lost 75 percent of
their endemic species some of that is
due to climate change habitat loss but
it's also due to avian disease
we've been trying to figure out how to
use some of the technologies that we're
using in mammals as in cloning to
actually influence and help solve some
of these challenges with birds
but the problem with the bird is it has
a very unique reproductive system the
embryo is tucked inside the egg
and the egg is a huge barrier
mammals with uteruses are actually easy
to manipulate it turns out
and what it's going to take to change
and actually develop Advanced
reproductive Technologies for Birds is
different it's called germline transfer
and it's actually been done successfully
in the poultry industry with chickens
and what we're trying to do is learn
from that technology and to apply it for
endangered birds
we've just announced a program called
biotechnology for bird conservation and
we have eight International Teams
working on this exact problem they're
taking different paths they're some of
them are incredibly synergistic and some
of them will be sequential but all of
them are working together to actually
solve this challenge
the way it would be done is you would
take those primordial germ cells from
the endangered bird and you would
transfect them into a domestic surrogate
and The Offspring would actually be the
wild bird just like we did with the
ferret
if we could do that you could actually
repopulate some of these small limited
endangered populations because those
common birds could actually have
multiple checks and multiple times a
year whereas the endangered birds if
they're lucky they get two or three
chicks a year maybe one or two survive
and you can't rebuild a population
I'm going to introduce Eric Jarvis one
of our scientists that we're working
with at Rockefeller University
my main line of research is
understanding brain mechanisms of vocal
learning the ability to imitate sounds
like we do for speech and there are only
a few species that have this ability
besides us humans like sombers and
parrots and whales and as I started to
get involved in comparing the brains and
genomes of multiple species I started to
realize that a number of them I wanted
to study are critically endangered and
that got me more involved also in
conservation because I feel like it's a
moral duty for us scientists to get
involved maintaining bird cells The Germ
cells that is for whatever reason is
harder to do than the equivalent cells
for males there's something about bird
cells that they need to be inside the
egg in order to develop properly than in
a culture dish my lab and many other
labs are trying to figure out what is
the magic sauce that these bird cells
need that we've already figured out for
mammals but not for Birds yet and when
we think once they figured out for Birds
it's going to be the same for reptile
files because the errors are basically
reptiles and they have the same egg
laying kind of system a lot of folks
think that conservation should be only
about trying to put fences up to save
species from population Decline and not
really get into the biology of you know
diseases of these animals or the
genetics and so forth I often have to
explain to conservation-minded folks
that putting up fences is not enough
what small population size times the
prevalence for more susceptibility to
disease human population growth is going
to continue to grow we must find modern
means to live in coexistence with
species without causing their
extermination and so
for my efforts in conservation
I'm doing them not only because I'm
fascinated by the science but also
because I feel like it's necessary it's
necessary for our survival
and the truth is
if Eric Jarvis and the other scientists
that we're working with are actually
successful someday we might even have
back the passenger pigeon
and when we do there could well be
another iconic species that was lost and
that's the American chestnut tree and
it's coming back
there were billions of these trees all
across this range
by the 1850s a blight came in from the
Landscaping trade that absolutely
decimated these trees and all that's
left is just the ghost of those roots
the good part of the story
is that for the last 30 years there have
been scientists at State University of
New York that have been trying to figure
out how they can create a chestnut tree
that is blight resistance and they've
succeeded it's really incredible what
they've done and they've done it with
one trans Gene from wheat this is Bill
Powell he's the scientist who has pushed
this forward
now his team has had to go through
incredible hurdles to bring this tree
through the regulatory path because it
is the first genetically engineered wild
species and he's really been a model for
revive and restore and the part that I
particularly love about his story and
and why we didn't have to fund them all
we had to do was just advocate for the
tree is because he actually was
transparent about the research that he
was doing from the beginning and I
believe this year is the year that these
trees will be commercially available the
chestnut is not technically our project
I just am a huge advocate for it and as
I said it's been a model for us for all
these years now revive and restore has
been involved over the last 10 years on
54 projects
and we've been funding projects in 16
Nations
and those projects are focused on 70
wild species
but wild species don't live in a vacuum
they require healthy ecosystems and
those ecosystems
include people their culture and their
values
now we were really excited when we heard
that there was a project called one
people one Reef
operating in the middle of the Western
Pacific in Micronesia and what excited
us about this project was the fact that
it was trying to combine traditional
knowledge with modern science with
indigenous people
let's hear from Magoo Mall
where we're from the Acton of eulipi
it's part of the Yap state in the chain
of what we call the outer islands and
it's basically about a stretch of 99
Islands in Micronesia
we were very subsistence Community we
depend so much on maybe 90 on our
resources our local resources so we
still grow our own food with very little
import
I think like many many people many many
Coastline communities we are facing
climate change and that's no surprise to
everybody but definitely not for us we
used to be able to predict certain birds
and certain fish migrate associated with
these weather patterns and those
Associated stars that we call the the
traditional markers now these patterns
have changed quite a bit and we can't
depend so much on on traditional
knowledge because it's changed and so I
think that acceptance of that and that
willingness to to seek further or new
information kind of started earlier on
we need to seek more information because
it's moving much faster than we ever
know so it takes science it takes you
know genomics and and DNA that is now
collected to the way that more accurate
count of assessing The Reef health and
the fish count it takes that kind of
Science and knowledge to be able to help
us make a decision on management
we've seen positive changes in combining
these wisdoms of the West and and
traditional knowledge and coming up with
creative ways to adapt to the first
decline in in some areas I think that
the responsibility now in my mind is to
spread this through the region on low
lines like us to join the efforts and
see from the 10 years of data of how we
can and we will be able to to fight some
of these fast-changing decline in our
reefs and resources
now the challenge is that nagul and his
people are facing may seem very remote
to everybody sitting in this room
but I suspect that most of you don't
realize that we actually do impact
endangered species in ways that you may
not even think of it
this is a blue bottle
it's actually called blue blood
and probably everyone in this room has
benefited from this substance
it's harvested every year from horseshoe
crabs
four hundred thousand
crabs a year are harvested on the East
Coast
they're impaled in these factories where
one third of their blood is drained
and the reason that you've benefited
from this is because of that blue
protein
it is used for every injectable drug or
vaccine that you've ever had or anyone
you know to make them safe safe from the
impurities in the manufacturing process
that could come in from bacteria in the
water
that Lal substance is referred to is the
gold standard for drug manufacturing
today and it's used with not only drugs
and vaccines with every implanted device
and it's used even in veterinary
medicine
but here's where the horseshoe crab
lives
this species comes in
once a year on the high tides of manjim
to spawn and it spawns in the thousands
of eggs every year
and it provides not only for the
proliferation of its species but also as
sustenance for wild birds and a whole
ecosystem
and these wild birds in particular this
is the Red Knot they migrate all the way
from the tip of South America all the
way to the Arctic Circle and they make
one pit stop in Delaware Bay to refuel
on the eggs of the horseshoe crab now
these feces are being listed they're
endangered they're not making it to the
Arctic Circle and when they're making it
to the Arctic Circle those that do are
so thin and underfed that they usually
are not breeding
this is a multi-continent ecological
problem and it's something that is done
for the welfare of humanity
that's why it's so linked to everything
that we do
but it doesn't have to be that way
and that's where synthetic biology comes
in
scientists back in 1995 at the
University of Singapore Dr Ling and Dr
Ho actually identified that unique
protein in the horseshoe crab that they
make the Lal
substance from and that unique protein
was synthesized and has been created
what was called the recombinant factor C
that RFC has languished on the market
because of corporate greed because
there's so much money in the blood of
the horseshoe crab
and it's also because of bureaucratic
inertia and Regulatory inertia we've
been advocating for the pharmaceutical
companies to do something to adopt this
synthetic alternative to force the
regulatory authorities to do something
we and other conservation groups have
organized a coalition and we've sent
letters Ad nauseam but one really bold
scientist from Eli Lilly has changed the
whole dynamic
I I'm a murderer so I have a unique
perspective in that I can see the impact
of the horseshoe crab not only because
of the horseshoe crab itself but the the
species that rely on yet including birds
and turtles and sport fish and all you
know anything that's in the ecosystem
that it's impacted and so we were aware
at Lily that there was an alternative to
the to the Lal test reagent we generated
the data but it took a lot of alignment
internally and then externally we had to
convince the FDA and other health
authorities around the world but we did
that with our data and we convinced them
we drew a line in the sand of 2016 and
we said that all new drugs that are
manufactured at the lady
we would apply the common factor C to
them and so our first product was
approved in 2018 and that was a
milestone because that was at first in
Industry approval of any medicine using
RFC per release and then we subsequently
had six additional product approvals
since then including our three covid-19
antibodies our goal when we set out was
to convert all eight of our
manufacturing quality control Labs at
the time to RFC and we've done that and
it's been Industries following we have
we have our peers sanofi and Pfizer and
roshnen Tech have all come out and made
statements similar to what we've done
which is that little converter water
testing and all of our new product
testing so there's definitely a movement
towards more sustainable endotoxin
testing
one footnote on that
America truly is lagging behind on this
adoption Europe Japan Korea have all
adopted the standards to approve RFC in
testing it's really our country that is
the problem the horseshoe crab has been
around for 445 million years it's
survived five mass extinctions and it's
not until the last 100 years that humans
have threatened it with Extinction I
believe that when humans
caused the problem we have a
responsibility to create Solutions
back Ten Thousand Years the world was a
very different planet
there was much more biodiversity but
because of our human presence we have
actually closed out so many of those
opportunities to let those species
thrive
we're at a point in time where I think
that by combining both conventional
approaches to conservation along with
new technologies and biotechnology that
we can actually Envision a much richer
more bio-abundant future it takes time
to make changes happen in conservation
the conservationists that we work with
in some cases they have to work at the
pace of nature
but the truth is they all live in the
long now
and we're all looking to see how we can
build a better future
thank you
I've got about three hours of questions
here
what kind and range of money would be
needed to run a national biobank with
samples of all the endangered species
and such a damn good question Kevin and
it's one that I don't have an answer for
um but I know it'll take an act of
Congress to get federal dollars to do it
and we should get that through
Congressional dollars
I am talking to people at the national
offices about this of of what it would
take so I'll tell you the federal
storage facilities are there the
databasing infrastructure is more or
less there
the challenge of getting field
biologists to actually add this extra
step in their process
it's not a big deal they actually like
doing it they understand the value and
in many cases it's a one-off I mean they
may get one at a time the cell culturing
with mammals not a big deal so you know
probably a million going into new
research on cell culturing is definitely
a number that is going to have to happen
and that could be for birds as well as
other species
but I think the biggest challenge is
actually getting the mandate to do it
and my goal is to actually get it
written into these recovery plans which
the biologists have to do as part of
their work it's you know this is their
job in the U.S is to protect these
endangered species and this is our
American Legacy if we do it right
you you give the example of where you've
worked with other organizations to help
accelerate acceptance and to overcome
things that just seemed well you know
what are in the political realm what are
things that need to be done maybe not by
revive and restore but you said
conservation takes time
and that's correct
um what would speed it up I'm not so
sure that it needs to speed up in some
ways you know this is this is working at
the pace of nature
um there's plenty of bureaucracy that
I'd like to to speed up and
um but but I think that
it's actually been a kind of a healthy
thing you know when Stuart and I started
this we wanted to socialize these ideas
to have public dialogue about it and I
think that's been good for the culture
people need to to actually realize how
important these Technologies can be and
to integrate them
a very long nourish answer
um two closely related questions here
um and I'm going to start with Jenny uh
and then I asked the second one which is
anonymous which conservation which is
revive and restore currently partnering
with and or which would you seek to
partner with in the future and part two
of that is how do you find and choose
your projects and partners
and how do you support them what are the
ways you support them
so probably the the biggest bang for our
buck of all of those projects is just
enabling genomic sequencing some of
those projects we may fund fifty
thousand dollar grants some of them 250
000 a few up to a million over three
years kind of thing but it's really
getting these foundational tools into
their hands and that's something that is
just going to get cheaper to do and
ultimately you won't need revive and
restore to do that because they'll be
able as a conservation organization or
land stewards to be able to just make
that happen on their own but for now
we're kind of a Gateway for a lot of
these organizations at that front the
bigger projects like the engineering you
know really thinking about how to
advance reproduction for Birds those are
much bigger projects now back to the
question of conservation organizations
when we think about how we're making a
difference our goal isn't to try these
ideas move the science forward it's
actually to integrate it into a
functioning ecosystem and we are never
going to be in a position to do that we
need the nature conservancies of the
world to take those genetically uh
resilient sea stars captive breed them
and reintroduce them to the wild that's
a huge progress process that has to
happen by other organizations not us so
we're the kind of bleeding edge try it
de-risk ideas organization enable people
to start to use these tools and hope
that they
get translated out to you know the big
ngos
so when you're
starting a relationship
you've been around for 10 years now
what does the Arc of the beginning of
the relationship how do they typically
happen and how does it evolve and when
does it take off well we've done a
really fun thing that we didn't know if
it would work very well but we've called
it um we started a program three years
ago called wild genomes and we ask for
people to apply for research money to do
sequencing on endangered or threatened
species but we put a very important
requirement in it that it had to be
actionable that it couldn't be just
purely academic it had to be something
information that once they gleaned from
The genome that they could apply in a
way that it could actually help protect
the species and so you know we've had
way more proposals than we could ever
fund so we're looking for funding
Partners now as we build out that
program and so right now we have a uh we
just finished an open call around kelp
ecosystems and we did that in
partnership with the Morris animal
foundation and
um and the web Family Foundation and so
they're kind of co-partners in it and we
actually have joint calls and we have
advisory boards that select the projects
in a really good healthy functioning
partnership so I hope we can do more of
that with funders
talk about intent consequences well I
have to talk about intended consequences
because in the last 10 years I always
get the question of you know we don't
know about the unknown unknowns and yeah
that's right we don't but we got to flip
that question and say what about the
benefits of trying things I mean when I
first started talking to Coral
biologists and this was really early on
and we could see what was going on with
global warming
almost everyone I talked to said it is
so desperate Ryan I mean they were like
going through PTSD diving they said
it's so radical we don't dare do
anything
to risk the unintended consequences of
meddling with the reefs and that has
really flipped in the last five years
Mary hagerdorn and all the scientists
that we're funding they're actually
saying we have to intervene we may not
have to genetically engineer we may take
those corals that are doing well on one
part of a reef and we may translate them
to another part where they could still
do better or we could you know help with
breeding and and
repopulating but some of them are
actually open to where the technology
will take them in order to save the
reefs so I think it's the risk benefit
equation that has to be played out and
um it just depends on people's tolerance
and I've seen that tolerance shift what
is a tool or technology that seems
almost possible that would make your
mission easier
stem cell technology I have a really
good answer for that one so one of the
things that I'm learning and again this
is kind of drafting behind human
medicine
is that stem cell technology is changing
everything in human medicine I mean you
know what did I just read the other day
that stem cells were being used you know
these are cells that are taken from your
own body that are then implanted to
reduce inflammation or to you know to
help with Parkinson's all these
different applications
but understanding how to develop those
stem cells has been incredibly hard
now they've never been used for
conservation not really and so because
of that
um revive and restore is going to host
this fall a workshop and I've invited
now probably 20 different scientists
that are doing stem cell research in all
different fields from veterinary
medicine stencils are big with horses
I'm an equestrian I can tell you many
high performance horses get stem cell
injections
they they do these things first with
animals and they do it with prized
cattle and prized horses
um and then they work it down to humans
I want to work it the other way and work
it for wildlife
so we're going to gather these
scientists together and we're going to
do a format that I've used in other
workshops which is really interesting
um we've done it now I think four
different times on different topics and
the secret to the success of this and it
really has been a success is we get you
know 30 40 different people from very
different disciplines
to all work over three days night and
day in a retreat facility and we give
them three different challenges that
they all buy into they elect and opt in
to different work groups and at the end
of the three days they're supposed to
identify the problem identify the
solution develop a road map on how to
get there and develop what they think
could be the translational Partners to
make it happen and the funders and then
I have a mock group of funders who were
present on the third day of the workshop
and I can tell you the night before
these teams stay up half the night
trying to get their decks together and
they pitch it as if for real
and what has happened on numerous of
these Workshops the funders stepped up
and incredible research has moved
forward one in particular on Gene drives
for rodents on Islands it was incubated
at one of our workshops and so I want to
do that with stem cells because no one's
paying attention to it and it's the
secret ingredient that will allow all of
these different projects to move forward
for engineering
there there was a question that Kevin I
peeked at it but he didn't give it to me
but I remember it was someone asking
could this technology be used to stop
invasives like no yeah could we do
something with the Florida python well
God I've really wanted to do something
uh it's a huge challenge reproductively
with the python so the technology that
exists that's been worked on with
rodents is called the gene drive and it
what a gene Drive does is it perpetuates
very quickly a particular Gene selection
through reproduction and what when that
happens you could basically create
sterility
now everybody is very concerned about a
gene drive for one species for example
getting rid of rodents on an island by
introducing only males right you could
just get that selection through and all
of a sudden you've decreased your
population but what if that rodent
escapes off the island and then affects
the good rodents other places that's the
big fear so scientists are working on
trying to figure out ways to create
both a self-limiting gene drives and and
they have lots of different approaches
to this so that that unintended
consequence doesn't happen even should
and and an engineered Animal Escape but
to me it's one of the most Humane things
we can do because what we do for these
species like killing thousands of
Burmese pythons
every year in Florida
if we could create sterility and remove
them it would be a much more Humane
thing to do
using rodenticides on islands has had
huge mortality on other species
especially Raptors who eat eat those
um you know sick and dying and dead
rodents
and they ingest the rodenticide so you
know working with invasive species is
huge now where they're making progress
with this because I need to give you
more success stories
yeah which is just a little this is a
good one oh sorry it's a good success
story okay so um
why
had MS mosquitoes introduced I think it
was in the 50s I I didn't study that
stat but in the 1950s
1850s oh yeah they came in they
definitely came in uh with the Whalers
and they came in and ship ballast and
everything else those mosquitoes should
never be in Hawaii there are five
species of Hawaii in Hawaii some that
carry human pathogens
like chicken onion yellow fever and all
these other things but there's another
horrific one that carries avian malaria
that's what those honey creepers died of
and it is causing Extinction like
nothing else
the big challenge is as these Island
temperatures rise the birds who used to
seek a refuge at higher altitudes where
the mosquitoes don't go now they can't
go any higher and the mosquitoes are
going as high as they can so there's no
mountain top to escape to
so
um people in Hawaii have known this
problem and they love their Birds
and they've been completely conflicted
about what to do with this is the the
animal human conflict that just keeps
playing out
and
um so the ins so Gene drives were
proposed I was one of the ones who did
workshops in Hawaii and just they just
went you know GMO forget it
um but there is a solution and there are
folks that came out of uh Google X Labs
that have used what they are calling an
organic substance called wolbachia that
they can engineer into the mosquitoes
that causes infertility in the mosquito
and also because of their incredible AI
expertise they've been able to
grow these mosquitoes in great quantity
because they can use AI to sex select
something that you know we haven't
talked about the role of AI and all this
but it's just going to be really
transformative for things like captive
breeding of small insects and everything
else
and wobakia is now being set for trials
in certain Islands it's really worked
its way through from I think having the
scariest idea of a gene drive to
something that now is being called
organic being passable but at the end of
the day it is engineered and it it uh it
will not absolutely knock out the
population of mosquitoes it will just
drive them down and they're going to
have to keep reintroducing these
mosquitoes over time you know some years
ago I was absolutely startled when EO
Wilson confessed that if all the all the
mosquitoes disappeared from the world he
would not object
I mean is this biological extremism
well
you know they
look I was a big proponent I did a
workshop and I I called it
um mosquito-free Hawaii I just I wanted
to get them all well getting awful why
it makes sense if they were invasive but
off the entire planet
no uh but you know
um
it's it's complicated
they're you know
many many species of mosquito they're
not all right it is not a charismatic
species So Adam has a question with so
many extinctions and populations in
Decline how would you prioritize which
species you focus on
yeah well so as an entrepreneur I'm
purely opportunistic I look for
passionate people
I look for science that's going to be
really applicable that can make a
difference
those are the biggest things that we
look for
um at the end of the day when we put all
the different wild genomes proposals
together we try to look at is there any
Synergy between teams that we could
actually you know somebody's working on
one part of the coral Challenge and
another could we put them together
um we look for things that are outliers
the project one people one reef and I
have two people from one people one Reef
right here
Nicole Crane and Giacomo who told you
about his genomic sequencing
um you know we look for people that are
really making a difference and that are
bringing us sort of a broader view of
this whole challenge of integrating
technology and I think magul did such a
nice job in that very short video that
he did from a very remote island at I
think some ungodly early hour to help me
with my talk
um you know Wayne that whole challenge
that they have between traditional
knowledge and new Innovative science and
how do they understand more about what's
going on with their their fish their
they depend on
because you know typically
environmentalists come in and they say
oh you just need to create a marine
protected area
you know just wall it off and you can't
do that when people are living on it but
can you say well let's have science help
us tell you how healthy that population
is and at what density it needs to be or
that coral reef what challenge they're
having with with their livelihood but I
think that that project in particular is
profound in that it truly is
collaborative they are really learning
from each other and
um
and I I think you know that that is
really my goal not on traditional
knowledge but I gotta say
conservationists are very traditional I
know you're using it in a different way
but it is an old school approach this
you know wall-off
and protect is one school of thought and
they are completely anti-intervention I
mean there were people when the
California condor was going to go
extinct that said let them die with
dignity
right I mean David Brower this dearly
loved person said let them die with they
freaked out when they started using
Condor puppets to feed the Contours they
said that would ruin Condors forever
that they'd just become fast food
condors and they're now 350 Condors
flying in the wild
on that note let's all give Ryan a hand
thank you so much
thank you
thank you Paul
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]